if if i may because
and this is one of the questions i had
in mind which ties really nicely into
this
um you most likely know about um jill
both taylor's
famous ted talk the stroke of insight
the one
where she goes into detail about her
experience of having a
hemorrhagic um stroke on the left side
of
her brain and then she experiences these
feelings of
euphoria and she goes into the state of
nirvana because
the way she's describing it she thinks
her the right side of her brain is sort
of
taking over and uh then once
her left brain comes back again then
suddenly she she comes back to
her version of the version of reality
that that we experience and she realizes
okay something's wrong i have to go get
some help
and well that talk generally was really
fascinating to me but
i just wanted to know your thoughts on
on that kind of experience
and and and maybe we can follow up with
the
idea of from a nor scientific
perspective the left and right brain
uh dichotomy that is created and the way
she describes it
now her talk was 12 years ago or i think
it was around 2008
and maybe since then have we had any
advancements any new discoveries that
sort of shed light on the
on the differences between these two
well i suppose my question is twofold
one is what are your thoughts on on the
on the way she was describing
that out of body experience in a way you
could call it an out-of-body experience
and and secondly the distinction between
left and right brain
yeah i mean i i don't have i miss i
don't have too much to say about the
first one about the sort of experience
of bliss or nirvana
so it's um
you know people again people will do
report these kinds of experiences in
in various conditions there are there
are examples
what comes to my mind are these examples
of so-called ecstatic seizures
so some people with with epilepsy
uh experience reliably
these moments of bliss and awe and
presence
of the numinous and all sorts of
wonderful experiences um either
in the in the penumbra or the periphery
of their seizures or maybe even during
the season
i'm not entirely sure uh to the extent
that sometimes they
would they don't want to be medicated or
they don't they don't want this
to be relieved from their seizures
because they they get
this from them um quite what's going on
for these sorts of experiences
is extremely hard to say i think and the
part of the problem is
it's been extremely difficult to
investigate them and
investigate them in controlled
conditions uh in the lab where you can
actually see okay this is this is what's
going on is it you know a wash of a
particular kind of neurochemical or
activity and this or that part of the
brain it's unclear so
some of these stuff from epilepsy is it
shows that
some brain regions seem to be more
implicated than others but but i
wouldn't
i wouldn't want to put too much
stock in those uh but it's a fascinating
class of
experience sure and i think again
there's a lot of
certainly a lot of interest um and there
has been a lot of activity for ages
about the neuroscience of meditative
experiences
and this doesn't it's not quite the same
endpoint but
but certainly there are there are
examples of people in
meditative states who will experience
the dissolution of the cell from the ego
and
and so it's kind of fascinating to see
back to where we started so what in the
brain can explain that kind of
phenomenology
kind of dissolution
an open question um the second
thing about laterality in in the brain
left
versus right hemisphere and this is it's
a huge
it's uh as most people will know
we hear these tropes and these cultural
tropes about the left brain being
analytical
and the right brain being holistic and
artistic and left-bringing
and as with all these things
there's a grain of truth underlying this
but it's only a grain
and pretty much for everything you do
the both hemispheres of the brain are
working together
some things are more lateralized than
others and so this is
a few of these saying a couple of these
things when you get more towards
output and input things tend to get more
lateralized so if you have a stroke in
one half of your visual cortex
that will affect one half of your visual
field
right if you have what a stroke in your
right hemisphere you will be para
motor hemisphere your motor cortex will
be paralyzed on your left hand side
so these things are very lateralized um
and that's not to be mysterious thing to
say
then when you get into sort of more
less obviously lateralizable things then
language seems to be basically the only
thing that's reliably lateralized in
terms of brain function in
in humans which is usually on the left
but not always
so most of the time it's it's it's
working together
i think the the super interesting
studies here
yeah so why i don't really like very
much decide this habit of
describing people as left-brained or
right-brained and you know i think
that's some kind of neo-phrenology
stuff um but
what's still really interesting are
these these old case series
these neurosurgical case series of
people with what we call
calisotomies these are people who've had
split brain operations
this used to be done it's pretty rare
now
because other medications become more
effective but for people with really
really severe and interactable epilepsy
one of the options was to cut all the
well the majority of the fibers
connecting the two hemispheres hence the
term split brain
and there's some absolutely fascinating
observations this goes back to
people like mike gazaniger and joe bogan
someone who would
uh you should give the two hemispheres
different input
to try and ask the question are there
are there two separate conscious
subjects
now um now that you split the brain
like this and there are
very suggestive hints that there's
something weird going on like you can
know you can show uh you have to always
get my left right mixed up because so
many things cross over here it's very
hard to keep
keep straight about it but if if i show
my hold on this has to be my right
visual uh
right forget about the location okay so
anyway if
if information data it's a bright visual
cortex that doesn't get into my left
then typically the person does not is
not able to verbally say
what that is because the left language
side doesn't have access uh but we'll
maybe try to confabulate what's going on
so the right hand side might still be
able to draw what they see and then the
left hand side
will make up some story to justify why
the right hand is drawn it and so these
are these are really really super
suggestive but it's still never been
entirely clear
this basic question of are there two
have you have you divided one person
into two or not
uh because a lot of the early studies
um turned out to have been
methodologically limited in in various
ways and
and so now with sort of more modern
methods
in the few patients that are stirred
around perception does seem to be more
integrated
across the visual fields than we would
have thought but but to me it's still a
fascinating
case about could we divide a single
conscious person into two conscious
people
and what would it what would it be like
to be one or other half